herzlich willkommen bei für den a8 es
geht direkt weiter mit paul ronzheimer
der uns sein thema afghanistan
mitgebracht hat da muss man erst mal auf
den tisch klopfen
seit drei tagen wieder hier aber was
mich bewegt und weiterhin beschäftigt
ist das was in afghanistan passiert und
die taliban sperren nicht nur frauen zu
hause ein wir wissen dass die taliban
homosexuellen fallen stellen über
soziale medien versuchen spule
aufzuspüren in afghanistan um sie dann
braun abzutöten wir haben das bestätigt
bekommen von verschiedenen
menschenrechtsaktivisten wir wissen dass
taliban
wenn sie schwule finden sie steinigen
oder eine wand von zwei bis drei metern
höhe auf sicht meisten das hat mir
damals ein taliban richter selbst
bestätigt als ich in afghanistan war
habe ich models getroffen einmal im juli
dieses jahres als die taliban noch nicht
an der macht waren das war eine
fashionshow hier sieht man sie wie sie
noch gefeiert haben dort wie sie ihre
kleider gezeigt haben wie sie glücklich
waren und jetzt wo die taliban an der
macht sind verstecken sich diese models
in einem kellerloch wo ich sie auch
getroffen habe in kabul und so sieht
dieses kellerloch aus und sie haben mir
gesagt sie trauen sich nicht mehr vor
die tür weil sie checkpoints erwarten
der taliban die jagd auf sie machen und
dass die taliban glauben dass die
homosexuell sind und deswegen können sie
nicht mehr raus ich glaube dass wir
afghanistan schon viel zu sehr vergessen
dass unsere politik sich daran gewöhnt
hat sich absurderweise gewundert hat
dass das minister kabinett nicht mit
frauen besetzt ist das ist nicht
das ist was man absurderweise gedacht
hat dass es werden könnte ich sage die
taliban waren immer grausam und werden
immer grausam bleiben
für uns heimat erst mal mein respekt
meine bewunderung für ihre großartige
arbeit das ssd journalismus stehen wir
in deutschland seit vielen jahren leider
nicht in diesen intensivität und
intensität gesehen haben vielen dank
dafür ich teile ihre
these taliban 20 die im westen als eine
hoffnung schirmer darstellung dass es
nicht so schlimm ist ein taliban von
heute ist nicht die taliban vor 20
jahren das ist alles märschen taliban
hat die gleiche ideologie ich befürchte
dass aus afghanistan ein land wert wo
minderheiten kaum rechte haben dass
minderheiten getötet und misshandelt
werden aber ich befürchte noch mehr das
auf taliban ein terror fabrik wird wo al
qaida und ihre strukturen aufbauen und
dann terror in der welt dann exportieren
wollen und das macht mir groß sagen mich
interessieren vor allem die fragen wie
wir damit umgehen mich interessiert
zunächst mal ganz brennend sozusagen
haben sie dort
ansätze zu einer opposition gesehen wir
haben ja mitgekriegt das ist offenbar
nicht nur in kabul mehrfach
demonstrationen von frauen gegeben hat
aber nicht nur von frauen aber von sehr
mutigen frauen die den taliban die ihnen
entgegen getreten sind gesagt haben wir
sind nicht mehr so wie vor 20 jahren sie
sind am nächsten tag wieder gekommen
sind geschlagen worden und trotzdem
wieder gekommen und sagen sie schalten
sich zusammen es gibt ja offenbar
restbestände von sozialen netzwerken
über diese sich verständigen das ist ja
eine ganz wichtige frage wenn es das
gibt also menschen die sich den taliban
entziehen oder sich ihnen sogar offen
entgegenstellen unbewaffnet wie kann man
denen helfen zweite fragt zwei zweite
frage ich habe hier meine dem tisch die
these vertreten wir dürfen die
intelligenz die afghanischen nicht aus
dem land holen sondern wir müssen die
dort lassen dann mit einer opposition
entsteht und damit die gesellschaft eine
hefe hat um sich umzukehren und die
taliban herrscher vielleicht irgendwann
abzuwerfen die politik ist ja schon
drauf und dran und zwar in einem tempo
das ich da ganz atemlos bin zu überlegen
wie sie lebensmittel und sonstige
hilfsgüter dahin bringt als wäre nichts
passiert also was zwei fragen was machen
wir zur stärke und einer opposition wie
stark ist die und die zweite frage diese
models die sie geschrieben haben sind
wahrscheinlich teil einer solchen frauen
opposition tendenziell und wie soll man
der gesellschaft helfen durch
lebensmittellieferung und andere ich
glaube die opposition existiert in
wahrheit nicht die sind im untergrund
sind entweder verstecken sie sich oder
sind stadt flohen die frauen das waren
am ende eine kleine minderheit die
sofort niedergeprügelt wurden ich höre
dabei bei einer demonstration um mich
taliban auf fast verhaften wollten dann
haben wir uns versteckt und haben von
dem dach gefilmt wie sie dort
weiterlaufen konnten seit tagen oder
zwei wochen gibt es keiner dieser
demonstration mehr und ganz im gegenteil
zudem dass man gesagt hat ja ja frauen
dürfen ja in die schule gehen wird schon
heute gab es die aussage des ministers
mädchen bis 12 dürfen noch irgendwie zur
schule gehen alle danach nicht dass das
ist schon das erste versprechen etwas
gebrochen wurde und was unsere
sich darauf angeht ich glaube
tatsächlich ist passiert mit einem
rasanten tempo also ich weiß von
botschaftern die schon an den türen
klopfen mit allen taliban sprechen
wollen whatsapp hin und her schreiben
die können gar nicht genug kriegen um
mit den taliban zu reden und wollen am
liebsten sofort mit pauken und trompeten
ihre botschaft wieder öffnen kann man
aus sicht des botschafters verstehen und
da kommt die große frage sie sprechen es
an die frage wie geht man damit um dass
eine krise eine welt eine hungerkrise
drohen könnte und da wiederum bin ich
der meinung natürlich darf man die
menschen nicht verhungern lassen denn
die unter den taliban sind die können
nichts dafür und jetzt eine dritte
unangenehme wahrheit insbesondere
abseits von kabul abseits von denjenigen
die geflohen sind oder die im untergrund
sind gibt es und das hört man im westen
nicht gerne auch eine große zustimmung
zu schade hier eine große zustimmung
dazu zu sagen das ist doch richtig die
schulen hin zu richten ist doch richtig
dass die frauen zu hause bleiben soll
also auch das darf man leider nicht nur
in afghanistan weiter empfehlen
muslimischen ländern sollte man sollte
man lebensmittel und sonstige
hilfslieferung mit politischen
bedingungen verbinden auf jeden fall
sollte man das ich habe nur das gefühl
dass alle bedingungen die unser
außenminister heiko maas formuliert hat
unter anderem dass frauen in der
regierung sein sollen was ist denn
eigentlich scheißegal es
zusammengebrochen wahrheit im
diskutieren die momentan das
interessante ist die taliban gehen
natürlich auch gegenseitig aufeinander
los ja dann gibt es gerüchte der eine
ist tot der andere ist noch unter der
couch ich habe eine sache dort erlebt
das halt viele die dort aus den regionen
aus den dörfern kommen
von den taliban diese stadt in kabul zum
beispiel gar nicht gewöhnt sind und dann
sagte ein taliban zu mir ja alles ganz
schwer hier weil früher habe ich immer
nur fladenbrot gegessen und jetzt diese
ganzen speisen wall-e ohne große
probleme auch bei den taliban also aber
es symbolisiert das auch intern bei den
großen
mit den kollegen eine sache einbringen
an euch beide wurden und zwar der
staatshaushalt der taliban der stadt dem
economist kam er zum ganz großen teil
aus amerika die gelder werden ja
vermutlich jetzt gerade nicht mehr
fließen also ich glaube dass auch die
beiden versuchen wird weiter ein kontakt
zurückzahlen zu haben denn am ende
werden die amerikaner naiv wie sie
momentan in ihrer politischen sichtweise
sind denken und da kommen wir zu dem
terror thema wenn wir die taliban
unterstützen ja dann mensch dann können
wir was gegen al qaida unternehmen und
gegen eis ist dann passiert da ja nichts
dieser absurden lüge ist man schon mal
gefolgt und wir haben gesehen was dann
passiert ja also ich hab mich da mal
einschalten darf punkt eins
afghanistan ein land das seit
wie weit über tausend jahren immer mal
wieder erobert wurde alexander der große
war dort aber ich glaube ja zum klügsten
gemacht er war nur ganz schnell drehen
dann ist sie wieder rausgegangen alle
anderen mächte alle großmächte die
engländer die russen jetzt auch die
amerikaner haben sich einfach nur
fürchterlich blutige nase geholt und
alle haben den gleichen fehler gemacht
ich habe das land völlig falsch
eingeschätzt wie man sie haben das bild
das auch super wie sieht das gibt es
aber der blieb das ganze mediale system
in deutschland aus den angeln gehoben
und bericht
die wahlmaschine dauert die worden ein
einsatzkommando unglaublich aber mich
frappiert einfach wie hat diese
angeblich so wahnsinn die klugen
politiker und mächte und strategen immer
wieder die gleichen fehler machen
glauben wir schaffen das wie gehen da
reinbringen und was jetzt ist und das
ist ja das aufwühlende ich finde das
fürchterlich wir haben das ja schon
thematisiert in dieser sendung werde ich
die amerikaner medizin
aufgaben im stich lassen mit ihrer
präsenz ich mein man muss ganz klar
sagen die amerikaner haben der
afghanischen armee über nacht die
unterstützung entzogen die luft
unterstützt worden und haben sie noch
bereit ich glaube ich wirklich können
nicht kämpfen die kämpfe haben
zehntausende von leuten geopfert im
bürgerkrieg geben die auf geordnet die
amerikaner haben sie schmählich im stich
gelassen komplettes versagen der
amerikanischen regierung außer punkt 1
die amerikaner sind hier in einer
wichtigen verantwortung das ist jetzt
zum glück nicht die hauptverantwortung
der deutschen was muss man machen im
umgang mit so einem land punkt eins
emotionen dürfen sich nicht leiten
lassen in der außenpolitik
[Musik]